bitcoin has been the official currency
of el salvador for an entire year so
how's it going well here's what the
media is saying the results have been
mixed at best president bucheller has
invested nearly 100 million dollars of
public money on bitcoin most of the
coins have not risen in value since
being bought using bitcoin remains a
challenge
at this grocery store we held up a line
for 10 minutes as the cashier waited for
our payment to clear they said that the
transaction was declined but on my
bitcoin wallet it showed that it had
gone through
okay so
it doesn't look great from the start and
with the imf telling el salvador to
ditch bitcoin and rethink crypto we
might be tempted to end the video there
but bitcoiners would say that's a
mistake of course the imf international
monetary fund wants people to rethink
bitcoin just last week the international
horse fund was telling people to rethink
cars in fact maybe all this fud from the
lame stream media is just them fighting
against the future that will make them
obsolete that's what the bitcoiners
would say they think el salvador is the
first in a long line of dominoes it's
the first of many countries that will
inevitably accept bitcoin these are just
technical glitches these price falls i
mean they're just hiccups in a longer
plan but
then again
bitcoiners aren't exactly unbiased
themselves of course they're going to be
fans of el salvador with it becoming a
crypto tax haven billionaires became
fans of the cayman islands for the same
reason so yeah i'm kind of sick of
hearing from bitcoin bros too in fact
everyone is even the family members of
these guys are starting to put their
foot down here's one of the most popular
bitcoiners saying that he's actually
been banned from his family's
thanksgiving all because of bitcoin so
uh max is is thanksgiving uh we didn't
even notice it because uh we're not in
america
um but uh what do you what the hell are
you doing here even though it's
thanksgiving right well simon you know
um we didn't get invited to any of our
families thanksgiving this year because
they're so sick of us talking about
bitcoin
uh we tried uh they hung up on us
they're just like
go away we're sick of you
that's why i always say you don't talk
religion politics or global financial
policies at the dinner table you just
don't do it that by the way is max
kaiser and in addition to being on the
thanksgiving do not call list he's also
one of the reasons that el salvador
planned to issue volcano bonds this is a
scheme to use geothermal energy from
their volcanoes to mine bitcoin of
course all that computer mining
equipment cost money so the government
was going to issue bonds to pay for all
that new infrastructure but at the last
minute has delayed the fundraising so
this is quite a complicated story
there's a lot of competing stakeholders
who all want you to believe something
different but what i want to know is
what is the truth what's the real
situation with bitcoin in el salvador a
year later it's time for a deep dive on
this
we're gonna start at the most obvious
place price obviously a lot of the
conversation around bitcoin for el
salvador is going to center around how
it has performed as an asset and here
things aren't great el salvador bought
the dip many times and then the dip
dipped many times they spent over a
hundred million dollars on bitcoin in
total at an average price of 45 000
bitcoin is now worth roughly 20 000
which means they've taken a 50 loss on
these purchases which is a huge waste of
resources so sure you could say they're
huddling but this is a pretty big fail
but of course that's not the whole story
a big reason bitcoin sounded promising
in a place like el salvador is because a
large amount of money being sent there
is from overseas this is often called
remittances and these international wire
transfers cost a ton in fees for el
salvador and the idea is is that some of
that money they could save if they use
bitcoin because in theory if bitcoin
could lower transaction fees abroad even
if it did nothing else that could be a
net win for el salvador but this only
works if people actually use bitcoin and
that's kind of a problem because this
isn't silicon valley where everyone has
a phone crypto and borderline
personality disorder this is el salvador
70 of their citizens don't even have a
bank much less cryptocurrency so
it might be a huge challenge for el
salvador to get its citizens to actually
even use crypto in the first place and
that's what we're going to talk about
next adoption el salvador's plan for
crypto adoption is actually pretty
simple they want their citizens to
download something called chivo which is
a crypto wallet app and here they've
been pretty successful chivo has four
million downloads and almost 70 percent
of el salvadorians say they know about
this app however this is where the good
news for el salvador sort of ends
because a working paper by nber or
this
they say that the primary interest in
chivo was driven by a 30 bonus that the
government gave away with each sign on
which for context minimum wage in el
salvador is only 12
a day so downloading chivo and getting
30
for free was the equivalent for some of
working almost three days straight so
it's a no-brainer now of course the
government would hope that people would
continue to use this chivo app well
after they've spent their initial free
thirty dollars but a survey from that
same paper shows that this is probably
not the case sixty percent of el
salvadorians said no to the question of
using chivo after the thirty dollar
bonus and over seventy percent haven't
loaded money onto chivo beyond the free
bonus so a lot of people were just using
it for the free handout not only that
even if you have bitcoin on your app
it's hard to use in el salvador since a
reported 80 percent of businesses do not
accept it as legal currency despite it
being so with all of that said where
does that leave us with our earlier
question about remittances and money
being sent overseas well the numbers are
in depending on who you're asking and
over what time period remittances
through crypto are roughly 1.6 to 3.9
of the total value of remittances which
is is not is not good because one of the
key arguments for bitcoin is that it's
going to be used for this thing right
it's going to lower international fees
but in order for that to happen you have
to use it so the most optimistic
scenario here is that people haven't
figured out that it's good for that or
that more people are going to use chivo
in the future however a lot of reports
say that el salvadorians just don't
trust bitcoin to hold its value which
you can hardly blame them for given
their experience with it but speaking of
that holding its value this brings us to
another argument for bitcoin which is
about banking or more specifically
people who don't have banking as i said
earlier the majority of people know
software don't have access to financial
institutions as this reporter for cnbc
explains 70 of people in el salvador
don't have access to bank accounts so
for them the concept of having a savings
account is almost foreign and those are
the types of reasons that the the
government is putting forward uh to try
to uh get this widespread uh adopted all
right that argument makes sense crypto
is going to allow people without a bank
to have one and that could be really
cool however there's still problems here
because that same survey it turns out
shows that the people who are most
likely to know about chivo and
cryptocurrency are exactly the people
who don't need it they are most likely
already banked and already educated have
cell phones with internet this is sort
of the opposite of the typical profile
of the unbanked you'd be theoretically
targeting so those are the main
arguments for and against bitcoin within
el salvador and that's how it's been
doing on each of those things from price
to adoption
you know remittances and also access to
banking
and it's been pretty rough i have to
admit however remember that el
salvador's decision still has some vocal
supporters which i don't want to neglect
starting with the actual el salvadorians
some would say that bitcoin is a huge
benefit to them because it allows them
to do things like pay electric bills in
a way they could never do before
[Music]
how long
more or less would it take you in the
past
to do the same thing
[Music]
three hours and now it's just
boom instant in your phone let's see
okay look that's honestly heartwarming i
have to admit and if there's a silver
lining here it's people like that
benefiting but in the press i have to
say those aren't really the people on
the front lines pushing the bitcoin
narrative forward in el salvador that
award goes to rich people who don't get
invited to thanksgiving but do get el
salvadorian citizenship via the
president himself because of volcano
bond
donations so the idea was floated hey
you know put a hundred thousand into
these volcano bonds and you're on the
fast track to citizenship or permanent
residency so i tweeted that you know i'm
we're very interested in this we would
love to become
salvadorian citizens and
within a half hour we were getting
tweets back and feedback
back from the president and other people
in the government saying you know we'll
make you citizens um
asap you know by the end of this year
okay this finally brings me to my main
question i want to leave you with
right because people on the bitcoin side
are going to say it's going great people
anti you know crypt are going to say oh
it's always going terrible but i really
want to leave you with this thought who
is the bitcoin push benefiting obviously
in the press it's all to help the poor
people right we have to
bank the unbanked but if you actually
look at what el salvador has done
not what they say they're doing
you really have to wonder whether this
is about helping poor people or if it's
about helping people who are already
well off i mean if you look at their
plan to issue volcano bonds to wealthy
investors they're giving citizenship to
wealthy investors they're giving a tax
haven to wealthy investors they're
planning a bitcoin city supposedly in
the shape of a bitcoin the thing
literally looks like el dorado you think
most of the citizens are going to be
able to live there they plan to look out
at the top of the volcano that looks
like you're going to sacrifice to the
satoshi gods i mean who are you catering
to at this point if the answer is
thanksgiving refugees that's fine but at
least say that and be honest about it
because from where i'm sitting i see
most of the benefit going to the people
already at the top so anyways that's
basically my assessment of el salvador
next year we'll check in again to see
how it's doing see if things have
changed because remember it's still
early so maybe everything turns around
and the bitcoin bros are right i i don't
know i'm open to that either way pump
the stock thanks for watching and i will
see you in the next one